He married a 6-year-old and then
consummated her at 9, and then my heart
like sunk to my stomach. Muhammad
married Aisha. I give a damn. 80 years
old, whatever. Why does it matter? It
doesn't matter to me. Like, "Oh, your
prophet married her. So what?" We will
curse the Jews. We will Oh Allah, give
them cancer, destroy them, curse the
curse America, Allah. Our prayers are
more of a curse instead of a prayer for
Jews and Christians.
>> I used to spit at churches when I'd walk
by. If I see the cross, I'd look away. I
had a dream one day about Jesus. And I
was lost and like suddenly a light came
up and like tried to lift me up and it
was like the sign of cross. And I was
like, "Oh my god." And I felt so
peaceful.
>> As he spoke, the spirit of God just fell
on me and it was just like I looked up
and Jesus was right there. I was [music]
dead and I came to life.
>> I had a dream and I walking next to him
on water. We're walking towards
Jerusalem and it was such a beautiful
dream and the peace that I felt, you
know? I had nothing and I I cried. I
called my friend and I shouted at him. I
abused him. I was like, "You made me
lose my hope and everything." He
listened to me and I was crying and I
was shouting and that was the end of
Islam that day.
And
my brother, he's a Christian. And like
one day I was talking with him and like
where he was like asking me about like
my religious stuff and like what I
believed in and whatnot. And I was like,
"Yeah, like I'm about to take my shahada
or whatnot. I'm about to become a
Muslim." And then he was like, "Bro,
like do you know who Muhammad is?" I'm
like, "Yeah, like that's the prophet."
Like, "Well, what's wrong with that?"
He's like, "Do you know who he married?"
I'm like, "Nah, like what you mean?" And
then he kind of just told me like off
rip. He's like, "Yeah, like he married a
6-year-old and then consummated her at
9." Yeah.
>> And then my heart like sunk to my
stomach and I'm like, You mean wait, you
mean you mean to tell you the Dawah guys
didn't tell you this? Nope.
Ain't no
>> I don't even think he knew it at the
time. And he was born Muslim.
>> [clears throat]
>> But um yeah, like my heart sunk to my
stomach and like immediately like I knew
that wasn't, you know, right. Like it
doesn't take a rocket science to know
whether that's right or wrong. Right.
So, I kind of like right there it kind
of died for me. Like I was like, yeah,
there's no no way in that I'm ever
following a man that did anything like
that because I have nieces that are like
around that age and they're Arabic. So,
like I was literally talking to my
girlfriend the other day and I was like
crying about it because, you know, it
hurts me to see something like that
happen and it happens today still. So,
like it was it was crazy. Yeah. Wow. So,
so do you have uh you got Muslim friends
that you're still connected to?
Yeah, so right now I'm trying to like
evangelize that same guy. Like I'm
talking to him. Um I kind of gave him
the the dilemma.
Mhm. But, you know, I want to get into
like the morality issue once we're able
to get past it. But, you know, he's kind
of like doing the hopscotch thing you'd
be talking about.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But, it's it's kind of hard.
My other one he's like, yeah, like I'll
never He's like, I'll never change my
religion because,
you know, that's what he grew up in. And
I'm like, bro, like if I show [snorts]
you this stuff and you don't believe it,
like what's going on? Yeah. Wow. Well,
at least at least you got out of there,
man. Um
it sound like you
uh it was right before you really got
indoctrinated that you like cuz you're,
you know, you was still
able to think and critically think and
you was like, okay, yeah, now this I
can't rock with this, man. Absolutely
not. Yeah, absolutely not.
But, like what would you say to someone
who was a is a similar situation like
you who maybe were wasn't born into
Islam, but they're, you know, they got
Muslim influences around them, maybe got
some Muslim friends, and you know, so
they're probably starting to think like,
huh, maybe Islam might be good for me.
What what would you say to that person?
I would say never just believe what
someone says. Like first thing I prayed
for joining Christ was like discernment.
Mhm. And, you know, it's grown so much
that I'm able to even tell like you know
pastors whether they're true or not.
Yeah. So it's like man like when it
comes to something that you're joining
like you have to really know what you're
going into. Yeah. Um and that's learning
you know from external sources well not
just you know internal because they can
tell you whatever like I've been told
stuff from you know Christians that
weren't true so Mhm. it's really
important to like read the books.
Absolutely.
All right. Hey man I appreciate you
coming up and sharing that man. God
bless you bro. I was raised Muslim. My
father's Muslim.
And when I was a kid
I was born in America but I moved to the
West Bank
when I was nine years old cuz my parents
divorced.
And when I was there I went to a Muslim
school. I learned Islam. I was
spiritually hungry and I uh And so
I became a Muslim. I was very devout and
I was very committed. I used to you know
this is pretty pathetic but you know I
used to
I used to spit at churches when I'd walk
by. I hate
>> Did you really? Yeah I used to spit at
the uh
at
uh if I see the cross I'd look away. You
know it was almost like I was a vampire
you know.
Wow. That's crazy. Guys if you guys
don't know now
he was looking away at the cross now he
carries one when he goes and ministers.
Uh with with Muslims he carries the
cross. Oh man that's awesome. Go ahead
go ahead. I don't I don't want to
interrupt man. Go ahead keep going.
But you know um
but I was I was very committed Muslim. I
wanted to preach to uh
to Christians. I wanted to come back to
America to preach to Christians because
I was afraid you guys are all going to
hell and I wanted you I was sincerely
concerned about you. I wanted you to
to know Islam.
And I had a little sermon that I wanted
to do on the you know we used to have
what's called show and tell in school
and I wanted to go do my show and tell
and say, you know, the Jews believe in
Moses, the Christians believe in Moses
and Jesus and the Muslims believe in
Moses, Jesus and Muhammad so you guys
should all become Muslims, you know. And
so they
that was my little sermonette.
But um
on the night of Easter of 1978 I was 15
years old. I was watching Oral Roberts
Crusade. He's a old healing evangelist
from the 50s and 60s and
he's the one who built Oral Roberts
University in in Tulsa.
And he was preaching about Jesus rising
from the dead cuz it was Easter of
course and as he spoke the spirit of God
just
fell on me. And it was as I looked up
and Jesus was right there.
And I didn't see him with my eyes. I
know he was right there. Yeah. And and
when he came I knew he's the son of God.
Mhm. And
uh you know, it's like I didn't say I I
was a Muslim and I became a Christian. I
was dead and I came to life. Mhm. And
and this is what God says in the last
days I'm going to pour out my spirit on
all flesh. That's what he did for me.
And so it was and and with a lot of
Muslims who come to the Lord there's
something like that happens a dream a
vision I've seen on many of your
programs with the Muslims who come to
the Lord here and
>> Yeah. So anyway, that's what happened to
me. It was so real. It was so powerful.
Yeah. There's no denying it and
so anyway, I just wanted to kind of
share that and thank you for giving me
an opportunity to share that. So
>> Wait, stay I got questions man. I got
questions.
>> Well, I'm here.
>> So so when you
around what age were you when you
finally left Islam officially? Well,
that was it was that night at when I was
15. You know, I was 15 years old and uh
uh you know, I always I hated
Christianity. I hated the church, but I
loved Jesus, you know? And uh
even as a kid, you know, my mom was
Catholic. She's from Brazil. And so, I
would get little glimpses of of Jesus,
you know? And uh I I used to always ask
my mom, "Tell me about Jesus. Tell me."
But but because my father was Muslim,
there was an agreement in my family that
uh we would be brought up Muslim.
And uh my name is Hussein, which is my
grandfather's name, and even though
that's a Shiite name, uh my family was
Sunni.
And uh
so, you know, I was
you know, just taught Islam and um I was
very much I was 100% convinced that
Islam is the last religion, Muhammad's
the last prophet, yeah, and the Quran is
the last book. And but you know, one
thing is that I really admired Jesus. He
did all these amazing things. He healed
the sick. He raised the dead. He you
know, opened the eyes of the blind. He
He was killed for other people, and he
did all that. And and I always tried to
admire Muhammad, but I couldn't find
nothing to admire him about. I mean, he
was a warrior. He you know, and you
know, the stuff
there was no stories about anything
about him that was admirable. The only
thing I found that I that I thought was
okay, semi-admirable
was that he you know, he rode on a magic
donkey once. And you know, that was you
know, a very And he gave he did care
about cats. You know, he wasn't a dog
person, but he did like cats. And so,
>> [laughter]
>> you know, and I liked cats. And so, so
Yeah, see, man, that's why me and
Muhammad don't get along. I don't like
cats, man. I don't like cats, you
saying? I'm not a cat guy, man. I'm a
dog person, man.
Wow, that's a that's a very important
thing. So, What's What's your
relationship What was your relationship
like with your family leaving Islam? Cuz
you said your mom was Catholic, but your
dad Yeah, my mom
My mom had left the family, and so, I
hadn't seen her for like 6 years, you
know, but uh and I I I I hated my mom at
that point, you know, because we
considered her, you know, she left us
and stuff. And but the minute Jesus came
back, my love for my mom was renewed.
Mhm. And I loved her again, and it was
just like the Holy Spirit just rebirthed
my love for my mom. Yeah. But when when
I became a Christian when the Lord came
to me, it was after Saturday Night Live,
you know, I used to watch Saturday Night
Live all the time. This is the This is
before you were born, man. This is 1978.
And
uh
so, after Saturday Night Live, there was
this Oral Roberts crusade, and I was
just, you know, laying around the house,
you know, I wasn't wearing a shirt.
But when the Holy Spirit came like that,
I knew
that I had to make a decision, and I
knew
that it's a decision that could cost me
my life. Yeah.
>> Cuz Muhammad said, "Men but the dean of
octal who Whoever changes his religion,
kill him." Mhm. I [clears throat] knew
that. All Muslims know that. Yeah. And
so, I knew it it could cost me my life
to uh
to follow Jesus, but I knew that this
was the truth. Jesus is the son of God.
He died on the cross for me and rose
again.
And so, um
it was instant. It was so powerful. It
was I mean, it was instant. I knew that
I I knew I had to make a decision to
follow Jesus, but I knew it was going to
be costly, and I I
I went to that church that I used to
always spit at on my way to church on
school and I told the pastor there I
said this happened to me, you know, and
he explained it to me and told me gave
me back then they used to have what's
called the four spiritual laws and he
told me about how
you know, to receive the Lord and he
gave me a little Gospel of John
and so I used to take it home and my dad
um
I I would leave the Bible around the
house, you know, hoping my dad would see
it and and ask some ask me or something
but he never did. You know, my dad was
illiterate he didn't know how to read.
Mhm. And
but then I told my sister
and my sister she told my dad and
and that night I came home I was out
with friends and and then my dad told me
sit down I said and I did and he said
uh we're we're family, aren't we? And I
said, of course.
He said, we're Arabs, aren't we? And I
said, of course. And he said, we're
Muslims, aren't we?
And
when he said that
I remembered you know, I didn't know
that much about the Bible but I knew
Jesus said if you deny me before men
I'll deny you before the Father. Yeah.
And and I said I said, no dad I'm not a
Muslim anymore.
And he said, why?
And I said, well, you know, I'm happy
this way and you know, he he threw a
shoe at me and kicked me out. No. That's
a light that's light-hearted compared to
what most people go through but
>> Yeah.
But before I left he took me back and
then he tried to brainwash me back into
Islam and uh
but um
obviously I didn't go back and
>> Eventually my dad did kick me out and I
went to live with my mom
and because she's Catholic she let me go
to church Mhm. and I grew in the Lord
and uh
and I had a desire to go back to the
Muslims and everything I did in
in the Holy Land. I was a missionary
from '99 to 2007. Wow. Yeah, I
I was in Gaza Strip for 6 years. That's
where uh
and I started learning about
Islam more to be able to preach better
and uh
So
yeah, so that's kind of been my story
and uh
Man.
Absolutely amazing to see.
Absolutely amazing. One of one of the
guys in my early days that was very
inspiring when I would watch you cuz you
you used to do ministry close to where I
lived. So it was just a drive away. And
[clears throat] I remember when you came
Yeah, so it was I was good to you know,
I I get this bad luck sometimes when I
come there's not really any action, but
when I leave you everybody gets all the
action. It's just just the story of my
life, man, but
>> Story of my life, too, for me.
>> Yeah, but seeing your videos of you you
know, just out there bold holding a big
cross not caring just bold in the Lord.
Just very very inspiring, man, and I I
love you and I've loved you for all
these years and
I'm so happy to to see to see that it
how how you're able to watch us now grow
and be you know, to do what you do, man.
Do what you do.
>> [laughter]
>> Bro brother, I just want to I want to
thank you so much for what you do and
just um
uh I have this pastor who talks about
mantles. You know, that there there's
there's callings, there's commands, but
then there's mantles. Mhm. Mantles is is
something that like Elijah gave to
Elisha. And there particular mantles
that have come on America and among them
was Billy Graham's mantle, which was the
evangelism [clears throat] mantle. Mhm.
And uh and I kind of see that I feel
like there's a mantle on your life, you
and your wife, that God is using you and
I'm so thankful because my family, most
of them are not saved, but I believe
they're I believe they're going to hear
you. They're going to listen to the the
way you
dismantle Islam with so much wisdom and
precision. And I thank you so much for
your faithfulness to the call of God and
I'm so thankful for your dad and for
your your wife and and the the the
guardrails that God has around you to
keep you in the Father's will. And God
bless you, brother, what you're doing
and burn bright, my brother. [laughter]
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. God bless you. Thank
you so much for joining the live and
blessing me, man. Thank you, brother.
God bless you, man.
>> Love you, Steve.
Long story short, Mhm. I come from
a Muslim country and in my country we
are all not only all like 90% Muslims.
And does normal countries where Muslims
are the majority,
Christians are very oppressed and
they're always we always had as a next
Muslim when I was Muslim, I always had
that view of Christianity or just I'm
sorry to say this, but all they're just
misguided people and the
Injil was
How to say that? Yeah, it was not
preserved and it goes on. So, I always
had that bad stereotypes about
Christianity.
Yeah.
>> And I remember my story started when I
was around 15 and I started like having
puberty,
having like questions about Islam and it
goes on. And believe it or not, I always
asked about Aisha, the Aisha and I
didn't leave Islam till knowing
To be fair, when we asked and in Arab
countries, to be fair, they always tell
us, "Oh, it's okay because back then
women matured faster. Mhm. So, they
always teach us that uh she wasn't a
kid. She was just like she's she was
just six or nine, but she had a
full-grown body. Mhm. I actually
believed that for a long, long time
until I decided to become more religious
and I started looking and I was like,
"Okay, I need to be closer to God. I
want
to like go to heaven and all that."
Yeah, and the moment I started uh
looking into Islam, it was very uh it
was a shock for me. The reason that I
actually left wasn't like
I think it was someone before me who
said the same thing and I think it was
the same experience.
I didn't leave immediately. It was just
like by steps.
At first, you just give excuses. And
then you just doubt yourself. And then
you just deny it. Mhm. And then you go
into that whole emotional trip where
you're just like crying all the time,
just saying, "Okay, why me? What did I
do? Maybe it's me." Blaming yourself.
And at the end, you just reach that
point, "Okay, I just need to face the
truth." For me, it was not just uh
whatever the Quran said.
It wasn't just whatever the Sunnah. It
was the personality of Muhammad itself.
Mhm.
>> They never told us the real personality.
They always told us, "Oh, he's forgiven.
He's amazing. Whatever he did wrong,
they
If you know when you used to uh have
conversation with them, they cut the
Hadiths. They don't give the full
Hadith. Mhm. So,
I started from there and said, "Okay,
there's good things about Muhammad. Let
me see those Hadiths." And every single
Hadith I read, especially about women,
is extremely offensive. Just reading the
full version just changed my mind and I
just left Islam. Yeah, and then I just I
had a dream one day about Jesus. I had
two dreams. The first dream about Jesus,
it was like
I was in the open field
and I was lost and I reached like under
a roof and I was like and I was running
from something. I I don't remember but I
was very stressed.
And I was like, "Okay, what should I do?
Where should I go?" And like suddenly a
light came up and like straight tried to
lift me up and it was like the sign of
cross.
And I was like, "Oh my god." And I felt
so peaceful. And I was like, "Is
Christianity actually true?" Like we
were always taught it's not true.
I was like, "Okay, is it actually true?"
And I was like so scared and I was like,
"Shit, I'm going to hell."
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, because in this life you live
you're you're you're done.
And I was like, [snorts] "Shit, maybe no
no, it's Christianity is not the truth."
And as soon as I said that like the that
light dropped me. And when I woke up
like I still felt that peace. And that's
when I decided to start reading
Christianity. Wow.
>> About the Bible. Yeah, and I started
reading and I'm I'm a newbie in
Christianity to be fair. Just like few
months but I'm just grateful for that
light that actually showed me because if
it wasn't for that I would never I would
be an atheist now to be fair.
Right. Incredible. So so tell us then
Anna
what was your
your exit like when when it comes to
your family when you leaving Islam, your
family and friends. Were was that tough?
Do they know? Did you tell them
immediately or did they find out later?
How how did that go? I I didn't. I don't
think I have I don't think I have the
balls to tell my family.
>> Oh,
to this day they don't know? No, no. I
told my boyfriend at that time he's
Muslim and we broke up unfortunately
because of that. Yeah, and it was very
hard and stressful but yeah, I I don't
regret a thing to be fair. Praise God.
Wow, may God strengthen you, sister. May
he May he strengthen you and cover you.
So, you you you've been a Christian, you
said it's been a few months now. You're
new to this. You're You're learning and
growing. Do you have like a a church
that you're part of now? You have
Christian friends that you
that you
have are connected to now? Uh I don't
have a church. I still live in a Muslim
country and I can't go cuz of my family,
they don't know. I still like wear the
hijab and everything. I just hope like I
really try to be like my best act. I
feel bad for doing this, but I just do
it so they don't ask me, "Are you
Muslim?" And I know they ask me, I have
to say I'm not. I can't deny
[clears throat] Christ. Yeah. So, I just
try to avoid that question. So, I have
Christian friends, yes, but I don't go
to church, unfortunately. Okay. Okay.
Well, yeah, keep keep moving in wisdom,
sister. We're praying for you over here.
We You You know, your story blessed us
and
um I just really I I pray for your your
parents as well. I pray that their
hearts are opened and they're softened
so that, you know,
they they'll be able to hear you out and
maybe also come to the truth through
your testimony. Hopefully, one day. I
know that it's
>> [sighs]
>> it's crazy to think about, but man,
imagine if God uses you to bring your
parents to the truth as well.
It happens a lot like that, so.
Wow.
>> I hope so. I hope so. I just wanted to
add one more point and I'll leave you. I
know you're No, no, sure. I You know,
like there's someone an atheist, he he
just came up. Mhm. And I I I actually
understand his point because just from
ex-Muslims,
imagine like you live your whole life as
a nightmare. You're living in a
nightmare and you think this is the
norm. And suddenly, you woke you wake up
and in the second life, when you're
actually waking up, just you always
think you're going back to that
nightmare. So, you have to be protected
about what you believe in. Yeah.
>> I understand, yeah, especially
ex-Muslims. Absolutely. You You don't
after getting out of that cult, you
don't want to be caught up in something
else just like it, right? And so,
>> that that's that's the terrible thing
about these lies that Satan has put out
is that it it it it really deters people
from clinging onto the truth because of
their fear of, you know, what they just
came from. So, uh yeah, we can just pray
for people like that. We pray for
people. But, thank you, Anna, so much.
This is Yeah, you're you're awesome for
sharing your story. Thank you. That
before I even started understanding like
the truth of Islam, I had an experience
with Christ, okay? Interesting. So, I
was going through spiritual warfare and
um I was looking for healing and it was
like about a decade, you know, and I was
just like so frustrated and like for the
first like 6 and 1/2 years of this
decade, I did everything the sheikhs
told me, right? Mhm. Drink the water
that they prayed over, did the ruqyah,
ate the honey, the whole thing.
Everything they told me, I listened to.
Nothing was working.
And then I went through like, you know,
the spiritual side of it, you know, you
name it. Every door I knocked on, I went
to every culture, every people looking
for healing. One day, one of my
Christian friends looked at me and she's
like,
"You know, the only one that can help
you out of this is Jesus." And I looked
right at her and I was like, "What about
God?" And she said, "Jesus is God." And
I like laughed at her. Mhm. You know?
And I remembered what she said one day
when I was going through a hard time and
I just looked up at the sky and I was
like, "You know what, Jesus, if you're
there, I need your help, right?" Yeah.
Then things started changing in my life.
Everything started getting better and
better. And at that time, I'm not
understanding that Jesus is working
through my [snorts] life that I'm now
like covered in the blood of Jesus like
he's helping me. Yeah. And when I
realized that I'm like, okay, Jesus is
more than just a prophet, but there's no
way he can be God. And I stayed in this
confusion and I call this a state of
confusion because every Muslim on their
way on their way out, they go through
this like confusion because they're
trying to make make sense of everything
and some people will stay in this
confusion for like a decade, you know?
>> yeah. Wow.
I
stayed in this like state for about two
years.
And in this process I'm learning about
Jesus and I'm learning about Islam and
I'm trying to reconcile it, right? I'm
trying to figure out like how I can say
that Jesus is more than a prophet in the
Islamic paradigm, right? Just trying to
figure it out. And it wasn't until
um I met a couple of brothers on this
app. I don't know if you know Nazarene.
Yeah, Nazarene, yeah. He was part of the
pro-Palestinian um
um
thing back then and he would run Bible
study lives sometimes.
>> Mhm. You know? Yeah. So I joined his
Bible study lives. I'm listening to him
talk about Christ.
So I'm like, you know, this seems right.
So now I'm feeling guilty that it seems
right.
>> Oh, wow.
>> I got to get Yeah, I got [snorts] to get
closer to Allah. So that's what I did. I
started researching the Quran, learning
more about my Islam. Yeah.
>> And that's when I started finding out
about like, you know, what 65 4 is
really about, what 4 2 4 is really
about. very like grueling emotional
experience for me. And then that's when
I started finding these lives on TikTok
and on YouTube, right? Listening to you,
listening to Sam Shamoun. I used to be
one of the weirdos on the Werdanize
live. One of the weirdos live. Hey, no
way. That's you, Sajida. You was being
wielded.
No, Sajida. And you know, you know,
Isabelle? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, she
wiped the floor with me a couple of
times cuz I'd go up there and like
defend child marriage and tell her that
she's got it wrong and that this is what
it really means and she was like, "No,
sister, you're the one that's got
[laughter] it wrong." Wow. Tell Now Now
tell me about that, Sajida, because
yeah, you you were defending that. What
What What What are you doing as a Muslim
in that mindset? You're You know You
know the Arabic, right, Sajida? Yeah.
You know
So you're you're going through it, but
you're Like what is What's happening
there in the mind of a Muslim in your
mind? So I was told that this is
regarding like girls that have like
hormonal issues, that it's not about,
you know, young girls who haven't
menstruated yet.
>> Mhm. That's what I was told and I just
took it for what I was told. I never
actually did the research because most
Muslims don't actually do the research.
They're just taking it from their
parents, their grandparents, their
sheikh at the mosque.
They have no idea what it means. So it's
not like I was, you know, a Salafi,
right, saying that a 9-year-old was a
woman. I never believed that to be true,
ever. I never thought that it was ever
going to be okay, but I was told this
verse is regarding
um you know, women with hormonal issues.
>> Yeah. And then I was told that chapter 4
verse 24,
uh which is about right-hand
possessions, you know, spoils of war,
Yep. Yep.
>> it's about women who, like, you know, um
that are getting married. I never knew
that they didn't have consent. I never
knew that there was no marriage
involved. So it was like I was I was
taught like a distorted version of
Islam, but once somebody, like if your
desire is to know the true God of the
universe, you're going to be honest
about like everything that the Quran
actually says. [snorts] And this stuff
is
you know, I I couldn't uh ever be okay
with, you know, grape of women, child
marriage, wife beating, all this stuff
that I actually did my own research on.
When When So when you would look at the
you know, wife beating verses as a
Muslim when you were still a a weirdo
being wielded.
What was your thought process on the on
the plain reading of the verse? How
would you how would you try to reconcile
that with with yourself as a Muslim? I'm
embarrassed to say it but I would take
the feather explanations. Oh my
No you know that's that's you you was
full Muslim.
I'm telling you I was That's what I'm
saying. I was one of Werdanize weirdos,
bro.
>> Sajana we got to play the song for you
Sajana. Yeah you do. Yeah you do. We got
to play the song for Sajana y'all. Hold
on man.
>> [music]
>> Come on Sajana.
>> No.
>> Like you know what it means like Jesus
saved me from that and then like after
I'm doing my research and stuff I'm I I
know that Jesus is the truth and I still
have like my old Instagram post. I will
never delete it because I'm trying to
cash out who Jesus is and I'm like
posting about it. So that's part of my
testimony. I still kept my old IG, you
know, for that reason and
so I'm I'm trying to like figure it out
and when it made sense to me I was
scared. I was so scared to like come to
the full truth and I still felt so
guilty. I went to Umrah. I went to
Mecca. I did Mecca and Medina. My first
day there Logic all I did was sob. Yes,
I was with my brother and sister-in-law.
My first day there I knew it was
absolutely false and I just cried the
whole day. My first day there all I did
was cry because I guess like a part of
me was hoping that I could find
something there Yeah. that would keep me
in Islam with Allah because you know
when you're raised in the religion
nobody's ever wanting to say like I'm
going to leave Islam or I'm going to
leave Allah. That's never that's never
your thought process, right?
>> Mhm.
it's it's something hard it's like
really it's difficult. Like the journey
is very sad, but it was the best thing
that ever happened to me cuz I have
Jesus today. And then um and the 29th of
this month is going to be 2 years. 2
years that I that Jesus Christ has been
my Lord and Savior. And I had a dream of
him. Like right before I I I I you know,
declared Jesus to be my Lord and Savior,
I had a dream that I'm walking next to
him
and we're walking towards Jerusalem. I
don't see his face. I do see his hand. I
see his feet in his leather sandals.
He's wearing like a white robe. And I'm
walking next to him on water. We're
walking towards Jerusalem and it was
such a beautiful dream. And the peace
that I felt, you know? That peace that
that total peace that I felt in my dream
um
came to me once I did accept him as my
Lord and Savior, but on a totally
different level. Like just like the
dream like when I got baptized. Like the
moment I went into the water, it was
peace.
So now that peace is just like I'm not
saying life is perfect. I mean we don't
have I don't have problems, but what I
am saying is that when you have Jesus
with you, there's this peace that's like
it's indescribable. And I was dead. Once
you're dead and you come to life, you
know? Like it's just so beautiful. So
he really he really did come for me. He
really did.
>> Yeah, that's amazing. Incredible. So now
what what about your family? Your you
said your your bro- your your your
brother and your sister-in-law, are they
Muslim?
Yeah, so my dad is an ex-Muslim now,
okay? Which I'm really proud of and
happy about. He's reading through the
Bible. He's kind of like in a state of
confusion. I'm letting him do his thing.
One of my brothers, you know, he's also
on his journey. Um I mean slowly but
surely, you know, people are coming to
the light. I have younger people in my
community that reach out to me. And I
have a few girls who have accepted Jesus
as their Lord and Savior, but they just
are not open about it. They're extremely
scared. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, like
my household family, I'm very lucky.
They're open-minded and supportive, you
know?
But, it's like the the greater community
that's not as supportive, but that's
fine. I would have been ready like I
would have been willing to lose
everything for Christ. You know what I
mean? So,
Yeah. Well, yeah.
You you're blessed cuz I I was actually
going to ask you that about what what
was,
you know, cuz you you know, we we people
are scared of what's going to happen to
them if their family or friends find out
if their Muslim community finds out cuz
there's, you know, there's honor
killings. There's all this type of shame
and
um
uh you know, you get ostracized and
pushed out of the community. So, but you
you like you said your family was
open-minded and pretty supportive of
you. That's that's a blessing. That's a
blessing. [clears throat]
Wow.
>> Yeah, cuz you know why? Me and my
household, we're we're serving the Lord.
They don't know it, but they're coming
home. [laughter]
Yeah, yeah. I'm I'm I'm touching and
agreeing with you on that, Sajida. Amen.
So, what So, what would you say then to
Muslims who may have had who may have
these doubts? They might be in that
in that [snorts] in that era where
they're doubting, but trying to
reconcile these doubts and these
questions, these problems that they they
might be having. What What would you say
to that to that Muslim?
Keep studying. Like, get a Bible and
read the Bible and read the Quran and be
honest with yourself because like the
more they study the Quran and the more
they study the Bible, there's no way
that they're going to stay Muslim. So,
if you're coming to the Bible with an
open heart and open mind,
like and and you know, God talks to you.
Yeah. Like, the very when I first got
like Nazarene sent me my first Bible,
right? So, when it came in the mail, I
opened it right to Proverbs 8. And I'm
reading it and the tears are just
uncontrollably just falling down my face
and I'm just like this is so beautiful.
Like, how is this even real? You know,
because before as a Muslim, you just I
just looked at the Bible as a book
that's corrupted and it's in the drawer
of the like the hotels we stay at.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> it was to me, right? Never gave it a
thought in any sense, to be honest. And
I never thought in a million years that
I would ever leave Islam and become, you
know, a follower of Jesus and
you know, a Bible believer or any of
that. But
>> [laughter]
>> life is beautiful and you know, so I
just encouraging them to continue to
study and if really, truly your desire
is to know your creator, you're going to
find your way home. Amen. Basically, I
was I spent all of my life in Pakistan,
which is a 97% Muslim country. And out
of that,
the Muslim majority
Sunni Muslim majority. Shias are kind of
minority over there as in Islam. So I
belong from a Sunni majority family. I
spent all of my life like from a very
early age, my mom started teaching me
how to offer prayer and etc. etc.
And I from the from the age 12
like I remember very clearly that on the
in the at 11 years of age I had my first
fast. And obviously I broke it. I was a
kid. It was hot. It was hard and you
know, kids kids can't do it like for 12
hours, you know? Mhm. Uh but I was
ashamed because that night it was a
feast at our house because it was my
first breaking of the fast, you know?
First iftar. It was a feast. And I was
ashamed from inside that I actually
drink water in the middle of the day and
I broke broke it. And I was a kid. You
know, that's how what kids do. Yeah. Uh
but from next year onward till I remain
a Muslim, I never
left a fast of Ramadan at all. Never.
Hey.
Yeah, see,
that is why dogs are haram. Muhammad
didn't like the dogs, you know? The The
angels of blessings will not enter the
house of brother every now because he
has dogs in his house. No angel will
ever come.
Yeah, Jibril [clears throat] can't come
in here.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, so you never missed a fast since.
You never You never did that since.
Uh-huh.
>> Never since then and I had to come to a
Western country. I don't I will not say
where. Mhm. And
that is the first time I was exposed by
some polemics
and some apologetics because I had a
particular insect that what we call it
Um in in Urdu it's translate pretty
wrongly but you know, we call it you
know, that we had to preach Islam. We
have to give Dawah. Like that's that's
something inbuilt as a as a proper
Muslim.
So
I was I was like, man this uh
pagan Christian, I have to get him to
the fold of Islam.
Not knowing
anything about the apologetics that are
happening in the world. I had no idea
who David Wood is. I had no idea who
Christian Prince is. I had no idea what
was happening in the world. Most of
these channels are blocked and banned in
Pakistan. You can't even see them,
right? Yeah. And uh
I had no idea what's happening in the
world and that is back in 2015
2016.
Um
and uh we had certain discussions and
going on and it made me think and
reevaluate. Like for example, like
Muhammad married Aisha, I give a damn. 9
years old, whatever. What Why does it
matter? You know, it it it doesn't
matter to me. Like, oh your prophet
married Aisha. So what? It's God
ordained and so what? She was adult.
Like she was an adult. Oh, for in your
mind, you Christian. She was adult. Like
when you preach something since
childhood, you don't you don't matter.
When I was a Muslim in Pakistan, you
know, we used to say we will going to
attack India and we're going to occupy
the whole Indian land and then we will
have you know, Malkal Yameen as some
famous actress of India. Like that's the
young adult talk in Pakistan. We'll
we'll we'll have intercourse with them
because they're they're the Malkite
women they'll be our slaves. Yeah. in
shame. It was as a pride. It was like a
trophy that we will win and we will
bring it to Pakistan. We will bring it
into the fold of Islam. So, most of the
things that you will hear right now in
the western part of the world we do not
care. Like we we would like that was
trophies. Those women were trophies.
Like beating wives, shouting at wives
that's like
duh. We've seen that in in most of our
life. That that doesn't feel immoral
from inside. Unless you're exposed to
certain other culture, other other other
ideology and looking at it from the
other side. Like As deep it was.
That's deep. Okay. Yeah, that's deep.
You're saying you're saying that like in
that society in that world view it
didn't you like yeah, so what? Yeah, 9
years okay, yeah, that doesn't bother
me. Like like that's normal. That's
cool. You didn't care. Like most of most
of the if you if you go back in in time
a little 10 to 15 years of age
difference between a man and a hus- a
husband was very common. Mhm. It it
wasn't very
uh abnormal. Like yes, you have a lot
much more difference between Aisha and
Muhammad but you you would see these
kind of things very common. Like
multiple wives, so what? You know, in my
family many of the people have multiple
wives. Like I I won't say who who and
who and who but yeah, my my
first blood multiple wives that is very
common. It's like and then then how to
treat them because you know, when you
have multiple wives you got to you got
to be strict. You know, you know what I
mean? You got to be strict otherwise you
can't manage all of them and etc. etc.
So, things
were very different in my perspective in
my
>> [clears throat]
>> mind. It was very perspective and don't
run the song, man. Okay, I was a full
Muslim but don't run the song. Oh, no,
Adam. I might have to
>> [laughter]
>> Don't do that.
Yeah,
so long story short, yeah, that the
questioning and I would I always say to
every uh friend or Christian and
everybody, start asking questions. That
is very important. If the person other
person uh has a brain
and no matter where he comes from,
when you ask the right question, you
need to see his mind, his brain, his
culture, where he brought up. So, you
need to change and adapt and ask the
relevant questions like
For me, the first problems that I
received were
the moralities of Muhammad, not from the
Aisha, not from other thing, but so many
other things that we have in the Quran
uh sorry, [clears throat] in the Hadith
literature, where things goes
much more
difficult to defend. Like for example,
when Muhammad attacked and killed all
the uh men who doesn't have the hairs
few big hairs. Yeah. And a woman was
shouting and crying because she got
hysterical and Muhammad killed him
killed her as well and said, "It's the
Satan in her."
Um
and then Muhammad got excited because
she looked at a woman and then she went
to his wife and performed the action.
So, they they like I'm just giving you
some some example, not all like it's a
very short time. I didn't want to take
all the time. So, things goes gradually
in problematic situation and uh
uh when we look at the Western culture
because I was exposed to the Western
culture for the very first time. Like
for me, I was I was a frog in a well.
So, my my whole sky is as big as the
opening of the well is.
>> Right, right.
Coming into a Western culture and
realizing
that the sky is too big. It's it's not
as small as I always thought of. Mhm.
And I I looked at things from started to
look at things from a different
perspective. Yeah. Um so, I had
different gradual situations where I
first left left Hadith, became a uh pro
max Hadith selector, where I would
select the Hadith that I like, reject
which I don't like because of I don't
like it. You know what I mean? Right.
Right. Right. And uh
then comes that this guy after a year
and a half gave me Christian Prince. He
gave me a video of Christian Prince and
I was so angry.
Mhm.
>> And
all the abusive language that I had in
my mind that I learned all my life, I
just did all of it. I was like, I'm
going to I'm going to F this guy up. I'm
going to go to his channel. I'm going to
do this and I'm going to do that. So, I
listened to a few of other of his
videos. I start preparing. I went into
al-tafsir.com.
I went to Quran library and I I started
searching and I started searching. I was
like, I'm going to bash him. I'm going
to bang him up on on his own
Wait. Wait, Adam. Before you continue,
were you So, as a Muslim, when you're
hearing somebody like Christian Prince
knows the Arabic, he's really in and he
ain't soft. Like, he's he's getting at
Muslims, getting at Allah, you know, and
Muhammad. Did you Did you want to
physically do something to him? Did you
wish you could meet him in person and
beat him up? For sure. Like, that's a
very small thing. You just said beat. I
would have gone further.
So, like all of my life I've said that
many time after each and every prayer
that I would pray, I would raise up my
hand and I would say, "Oh Allah, give me
the death of a martyr." I never wanted
to die as a normal death. I wanted to
die as a death of a martyr. That was my
prayer all my life. Wow.
>> That was like literally because that was
the prayer of Muhammad as well as as it
was taught to us that give me the death
of the martyr because I wanted to go to
Jannatul Firdaus.
Not the normal Jannat. There there there
are levels of Jannat in Islam. So, I
wanted to go to Jannatul Firdaus where
only the martyrs and the prophets are
there, right? Yep. Yep. So,
for me, yeah.
Like, I I want to I wanted to make it
soft tone over here, okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Wow. All
right. So, continue now cuz Cuz that's
really interesting. Getting in the
mindset of a Muslim,
you know, getting, you know, seeing this
stuff, seeing these apologists, and what
it's like being a Muslim who's devout
hearing this stuff, that emotional rage
and and mental mindset. I It's really
interesting to to actually get some
insight on that. So, all right. So,
you're gathering up information. You're
like, "I'm about to bash Chris. I'm
about to bash him." Go ahead. Go ahead.
Yeah, and every time I research things,
the more I research, the more I get in
trouble.
Because like when I was in Pakistan,
we had the collection of the Sahih
Hadith. Like that's the translation of
the name of the book. So, what they have
like they have selective Hadiths into
one single book. So, Sahih Muslim, Sahih
Bukhari, Sunan Abi Dawud, Sunan Nasai,
and all of them into one single book,
and they were very selective. Um
Quran translations are very very
selective.
And
you don't you don't get to see a lot in
in [clears throat] those um Hadith
literature that we we study in in the
translation and all that. We just know
that whenever we go to the mosque on the
Friday prayer,
uh right after the Friday prayer, we
will we will curse the Jews. We will
Allah give them cancer, destroy them,
curse the curse America. Allah give them
AIDS, and etc. etc. etc. Like Like we we
our prayers are more of a curse instead
of a prayer for Jews and Christians,
right?
>> Yeah. And that's that's very common,
FYI. And uh
But like when coming here in in the
western part of the world,
you have Christians and Jew Christians
and agnostics and everybody around you.
And like the same Christians that we
will not even eat in the same plate.
Like we my mother had a special cutlery
for the Christians because they are like
dogs. We can't we can't eat in the same
cutlery with them. They are najis by
default.
Here, things were different, you know?
You you had to adapt. And and then I
spoke with one of my uh
imam and he said you can leave certain
Sharia tenants when you are in a
non-Muslim country. So, you don't have
to be uh and he he taught me certain
things and etc. etc.
And wow, you know, it was it was it was
a wow factor and the more
Now, that is happening and then this guy
is happening and things going into very
dramatic situation where I kind of
become a Quran-only Muslim kind of a
Really? Yeah, I was like I was stages.
It's like a 3 years that I'm describing
very shortly. Um and uh
that is the time when I saw the debate
that happened between Jay Smith and
Shabir Ally Mhm. in 2012 called the
classical debate between Jay Smith and
Shabir Ally where Jay Smith brought up
the Sana'a manuscript and the issues.
Yeah. Shabir Ally spent
40 minutes I think or 25 I don't
remember right now on the miracle of
so-called 19, which I knew it was
created by Rashad Khalifa Yeah. guy who
was killed by them by the Sunnis as well
and he proclaimed him to be a prophet.
And I knew what the problems were in the
19 miracle, the Surah Noon, the chapter
number nine, the last two verses and so
on and so forth. And I was like, what is
Shabir Ally doing? He's a professor.
He's a professor. He wrote so many
books.
And Jay Smith came back and the first
sentence of his destroyed the whole 19
miracle. He said the first sentence was
Shaykh Shabir, which Quran are you
talking about? Mathematical miracles,
which Quran are you talking about? Mhm.
And I was devastated. I was like
So, that is when I started to realize
that Quran even Quran has problems. And
then all of those thinking
came up. I knew Solomon was talking to
ants. But then
>> [clears throat]
>> when I have already heard Christian
Prince where I wanted to destroy
Christian Prince. Now somehow
I don't know how when the influence of
Quran is holy and perfectly preserved
goes away a little, you start to see the
problems in the Quran. Yeah, that's
where That's wild.
So the only then I started to realize,
okay, yes, there are problems. Let's the
Maryam cannot be the sister of Aaron.
You cannot talk with the ants.
The The sun and moon cannot be circling
the earth. The All of these problems
that are actually problems. The sperm
cannot come from the backbones and the
ribs. All of these problems that I was
defending in my own self started to come
up as problems
because now that I realized that Quran
is not divine. Only then you can kind of
get to see the issues and the problems.
The first and I would say
to the person who comes from a Muslim
majority country and not a Western not
born in West on the West or not raised
in the West, I I would personally attack
the Quran and Muhammad himself because
in in my part of the world, you can say
something to Allah and still survive.
But you cannot say something to Muhammad
and survive. That's how it works in my
part of the world. Wow. So yeah. So then
how did you How did you leave? Because
you you see these problems, you're kind
of Quran only, but now you're seeing all
these problems. What was it that finally
sealed the deal like, yeah, I'm done.
I'm done with Islam.
So
then I started studying more and I
started spending more time in the prayer
in the mosque. So my Isha prayer started
lengthening and I wanted to for Allah to
give me some signs, some miracles,
something or some way to defend this
religion, some way to destroy Christian
Prince. David Wood for me it was too
soft. I like, yeah, whatever. This guy
is whatever. Christian Prince, I wanted
to like
bang him hard, you know?
>> Yeah. And
the more I did it, the more it went
south.
Um
it was the time
uh where
my Iman was getting weaker and weaker
and weaker with every day because I was
listening to CP every day.
Yeah.
I I
I I couldn't just leave it. I I I was
like I was addicted [laughter] to it. I
I wanted to
do not do it. You know what I mean?
>> Yeah.
>> And
and I can't even find him where he is.
So, things were very messy and then, you
know, the more I watch him, the more I
have problem, the more I study because
of him,
the more I start to go away from Islam.
And finally, there was a night I
remember
when
I did the longest Qiyam and the long
longest Ruku.
And I was like, "Allah, it is today or
never." And I woke up the next day, I
did not do Ghusl. I took a shower,
normal shower, like normal human beings
does. The Ghusl um
I did not offer my Fajr prayer. I went
out of the house. I did not recite Ayat
al-Kursi.
I sat in my car and my muscle memory
started to recite Subhanallahi wa
bihamdihi. That is the prayer for the
traveling. And I just stopped
Subhanallahi at Subhanallahi I stopped
myself because I was like, "Why am I
reciting?" I started my car, went to his
office.
I was not in Wudu like most of the time
like I was always in Wudu. I go to the
bathroom, I do Wudu again. Yeah. I was
almost trying to be in Wudu all the
time.
Yeah. Zuhr time came, never went to
Zuhr.
Asr came,
didn't go to Asr.
Before Maghrib time, I started went out
of the house towards the house instead
of waiting for the Maghrib. And then at
that night, I was devastated because I
had nothing. And
I was I I I know I was standing outside
in in the backyard and I was looking at
the sky and the big sky is revolving,
you know?
And I was like, what am I? Who am I? And
that's where I had nothing and I I
cried. I called my friend and I shouted
at him. I abused him. I was like, you
made me lose my hope and everything. So,
he listened to me and I was crying and I
was shouting and that was the end of
Islam that day.
Wow.
Mhm. So, yeah. Then I was an agnostic
kind of a person. Right.
>> That's the second part of my journey.
That's part two. That is part two. But
yeah, that's that's that's that's good.
Like it took me like three three and a
half year approximately to come to this
conclusion. And that's why I call
everyone that don't be hasty with with
the Muslims. Work with them slowly.
And by the way, I I I didn't know even
know you. Like I know you from the very
first time when you came to By the way,
I was a Christian back then when when I
saw you. And I saw a young teenager kind
of a guy having a bag on his shoulder
standing in front of Othman. And he's
like, I don't know. You gave gave a
reference from the New Testament and he
was he was in the middle of the Bible
and he was going backwards. No, no,
Othman. No, no, Othman. It's it's it's
in the New Testament. The other way. The
other way. The other way. I [laughter]
was like,
this guy is going to be crazy. I I was
watching this and I was I was laughing
and I was like, this guy will be will be
a hell for these kind of a Dawah gang.
It's the [laughter] other way. The other
way.
>> [clears throat]
[laughter]
[gasps]
>> Yeah, that was my first
That was the first time I saw you.
It was good.
Yeah, I I didn't look like much. I
didn't look You know, you wouldn't you
wouldn't suspect anything from from me,
man. You know, I don't have I didn't
have the long beard and nothing like
that, you know?
Just a chill dude
walking up on Dawah guys Dawah hunting.
Yeah, you. Man, it's quite frankly that
was that was brilliant and then you made
him say every single Muslim prophet was
a Messiah. I know, like what? Bro. That
was beautiful. Bro, he surprised me with
that level of stupidity. I did not
expect that.
I did not expect that. But man, now
thank thank you so much. And so, Adam,
what would you say two things. One, to
the Christian who is trying to reach
their Muslim friend, um what would you
say to them and encourage them with? And
two, what would you say to the Muslim
who may be doubting, maybe listening to
our videos with a hardened heart, um but
secretly like, you know, they knows
okay, stuff is making sense or
researching. What would you say to both
parties? One, the Christian who's trying
to reach Muslims. And then two, the
Muslim who is in the middle of this.
Perfect. So, for all the Christians do
not Sorry. Okay. For all the Muslims do
not acknowledge their mistakes. Like I
when I came to the western part of the
world,
I was telling I was talking to a
Christian and I said, "We also do We
also accept Abraham. Abraham sacrificed
Ishmael." And they were fine. Yeah, we
we we acknowledge Abraham did sacrifice.
Dude, fix the Muslim. Don't be like
don't think that you're going to offend
the Muslim. If he's wrong, fix it. So,
because when you fix it in a nice way,
in a in a good way,
let him research on that. Let him Maybe
whatever when you saw this is I I call
the seed. Give him seed of something and
most of the seeds will go on the solid
ground. Nothing will come out.
But sometime someday somewhere in
in the future, somebody will have the
right kind of a seed with water.
So, do not stop in fixing the statements
that the Muslim says.
That's point number one.
If you are a normal Christian,
if you are
a educated Christian who knows the
Bible, and I have said that many times,
start with the most obvious attacking
position where you let him attack you.
Because he's your friend. He won't
attack you physically. He's living in
around you. He won't attack you
physically. But, like attacking means
verbal. For example,
I would pray in the name of the Father,
Son, and Holy Spirit
on on food. I'll ask them, "May I pray?"
"Yes, please." And I pray in the name of
the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit. There
you go. I gave them the most obvious
attacking position. Attack the God, the
Bible.
I'd let them do that.
So, and then I can progress further with
them. The The The thing is, if you are
going to ask question,
they're going to run away. But, if they
have opened the conversation, you have
all the right to continue the
conversation. So, start asking question,
start giving them opportunity to ask you
question, and then continue from there.
And when they say something which is
contrary to the Bible, but it is in the
Quran, and they are proclaiming the
Quran, and it is contrary to the Bible,
give them the explanation from the
Bible. Make him learn. Make him think.
Make him question.
That is for the Christians.
Do not hold back.
Yeah. For Muslims, man,
I come from exactly where you were. I
had the most hardened heart that I would
tell you for sure. The guy who has
always prayed to be a martyr
>> [snorts]
>> is sitting right now, standing in front
of you guys. Learn. Listen to what the
people are saying.
If you are going to say eventually that
you're going to pick the Hadith that you
like and not pick the Hadith that you
like, you're going to pick the
translation that you like and not pick
the translation that somebody else like,
then every single early Muslim from the
first 650 years of Islam were fake
idiots
and non-Muslims. That's what you're
going to say. Right now, if Qurtubi
stands here in front of these Muslims,
they're going to Qurtubi saying you're a
blasphemous and they're going to kill
him. They're going to say, "Qurtubi, you
are an apostate." If Tabari stands here
right now, Tabari would be an apostate,
will be called apostate and blasphemer,
and he would be given a capital
punishment. Think about what the early
people are writing. The closer to Islam,
the most closer to prophet, so-called
fake prophet of Islam. Think about what
they're writing and how they're
interpreting the verses. And think about
your moralities that you think is right.
Don't tell me that chapter number 65,
verse number four, is about some
exceptional cases. Mhm. Don't tell me it
is a miracle that Solomon is talking to
ant. No, the ant are talking back. And
how does the ant know that Solomon and
his army is coming up? Like that's
that's silly. Solomon can have a
miracle, not the ant. Like miracle is
not for the ant, for the Solomon.
So, the like it is crazy that even
inside the Quran, you have Solomon using
genies to build the temple. Genies,
because in Arabia, things were not
developed for for Muhammad to comprehend
how this beautiful, marvelous temple can
be built by human. He can't even
comprehend. He made the genies to build
the temple. Mhm. And he can't even
comprehend the cherubims and seraphims
because he didn't doesn't know about
that. So, he said tamaseel. They were
building tamaseel. So, for you, there
are idols in the temple back then. Yeah.
You would see certain things that has
been taken so wrongly from the Bible. It
is It is absolutely unheard of. And when
you look at it from a mind not filled
with, "Oh, Quran is perfectly
preserved." By the way, thank you,
Muhammad Hijab and Yasir Qadhi for the
holes in narrative. This is very, very
important that you need to realize
there's no one Quran. I have been told
all my life, my Imam, we he would he
would he would he had a small stick that
he would use on the back of my our
shoulder when we would not recite
properly. Because this is the word of
Allah, you have to recite it properly.
Really? There were not even diacritical
marks on it. No zer, no zabar, no pesh.
Now we have to recite it with zer,
zabar, kasra? That is so stupid. So, to
all the Muslims I would say, listen to
what we are telling you, and then listen
to what your imams are telling you, and
then compare who's telling the truth.
Learn,
understand,
know the truth, and you will only find
the truth in Lord Jesus Christ. That's
the reality. Amen. Guys, this is Adam
seeker, and you can find him and his
YouTube channel Adam seeker. Right,
Adam?
Absolutely, brother. Absolutely. We go
live every Tuesday and Thursday with
sister Hatoon, and we open many topics.
But like not unlike you, you are
rocking, man. Yeah, man. I'm addicted,
man. I'm I'm addicted. I can't get away
from this. Um, but yeah, you guys you
can find Adam at Adam seeker on YouTube,
guys. They go live. They give this
information. They do breakdowns. They do
a bunch of stuff, man. You can learn so
much, obviously, from Adam and the
others. So, make sure you guys tune into
them. Look them up. Subscribe. Support
the brother.
>> [gasps]
>> And
uh and yeah, have fun [clears throat]
listening to his sessions cuz it's fun.
>> [laughter]
>> Thank you, brother. Thank you. And I
would like to say one one more thing for
the Christians who are around new
ex-Muslims in Christ. That is one of the
most important thing that I need to say.
Yeah. Because that question doesn't come
up Yeah. I'm going to use your platform
and so many people that are here. When I
first accepted Christ
and became an ex-Muslim, we lost
everything. We lost our families. We
lost
friends. We lost
reality.
What do you What do you What
[clears throat] do you mean by reality?
I cannot go to a Muslim friend and act
as a Christian.
For a Muslim friends and families around
us,
they still think we are Muslims.
We cannot be
the same. We have to act differently.
So, when a new ex-Muslim who's in Christ
accept Christian Christianity, you the
church is their family. And the Western
culture
do not know how to be a family, FYI. I'm
telling you, that's my personal
experience.
They do not know how to be a family in
Christ with these new new family
members. For you guys is Christmas is
family time.
For Muslim, Eid is not just family. It's
family plus extended family plus
extended family plus friends plus etc.
etc. plus the whole neighborhood, you
know? Yeah. Christmas is not like how
can a new
Christian get his family members
additional family members extended
family into his house on Christmas? He
doesn't even know how to celebrate
Christmas. He's just new. Right. What
will he do at home? How about Easter?
How about other events? The the Western
culture is lacking
the family ties with the church family.
So, I would I would like to use this
platform to say, please, if you know an
ex-Muslim who is a Christian,
and he please give him time on these
special days. The Christmas, the
Easter, the other things. Give invite
him. He He He should be the one who
should be deciding which home he should
go. That is how many invitation he
should have Mhm.
>> instead of not having anything. Or go to
his home, like 10 of you, bring food and
say you don't do anything. You all bring
food to his Celebrate with him. Give him
time. Give him opportunity. Give
And acknowledge that he is new. He's
going to make mistakes. When he pray, he
might not pray like you. When he read,
he might not read like you.
You have been brought up since
childhood. He just came into the fold of
Christianity.
So, this is something very very
important.
And uh yeah, please. that's a humble
request to all of you guys. Thank you so
much, God logic. God bless you, my
friend. God bless you, man. Thank you so
much for coming up.